(air susurrating)
(airplane engine whirring)
(airplane dings)
- [Board Member] What's our AI strategy?
- I want efficient
customer service.
- I want faster
accounts payable.
- I want automated
customer onboarding.
- I want agentic coding.
(airplane dings)
- [Board Member] The board
wants an update on our view
and plans for impact of
quantum on our business
for the board meeting tomorrow.
(lightning rumbles)
- Show of hands, how many of you felt like
that pilot in that scene we just saw?
Right.
So as a former CIO,
it's been more than a few
times that my CEO has walked
into the room asking, "Hey, Arvind,
what's going on with this new technology?"
And in that instant,
I shift from being a trusted advisor
to a scrambling researcher.
And now at AWS,
as we talk to more and
more customers and CIOs,
this pattern is repeating
more and more often.
The reasons are very clear.
Over the last 25 years,
a range of technologies
have completely transformed
how industries in every
sector of the industry
and every function have
been transformed more
and more by technology.
And this is only accelerating.
Powered by a combination of technologies
that are accelerating and
creating more and more impact,
whether it's AI or
robotics or biotechnology,
the cool thing really
is that it's not just
that these technologies are
accelerating independently
in isolation, but they're
actually feeding into each other,
creating a exponential impact
that's accelerating impact
for businesses as well.
And the interesting
thing is that, of course,
this is not just something
which is hidden somewhere.
The media's talking about it,
vendors are talking about it.
There are industry events,
and your business leaders
are going into those events
and learning about it
there and they're wondering
why they're not hearing this internally
in your own organizations.
And this is a major challenge
that we've got to overcome.
Now the real challenge is that
it's not that our core work
of technology delivery is
getting any easier, right?
Our work is getting
more and more critical,
more and more central to the business,
and delivering excellence is
absolutely non-negotiable.
But at the same time,
the technology leaders
are also being expected
to be the innovation
champions, the scouts,
the people who bring in and
reshape existing organizations
to be more modern and digital.
This dual mandate is making
things more and more complex
for our roles.
Now I was a CIO about,
I joined AWS a year and a half ago.
Before that, I was a CIO for
Kellogg's based in Singapore,
and before that, with Prudential Insurance
and Procter & Gamble.
And over the last 10, 15 years,
I've seen this pattern
repeat again and again
where business leaders are getting more
and more interested in technology.
And the way I've responded to
that is I've leaned into it
and created a network of people around me
in the technology
organization and in business
that I used to call the digital kampung.
Kampung is a Malay word.
I live in Singapore,
so Malay is a language that's used there.
Kampung is a Malay word for village.
And this is a situation
where you want people
to come together to
address this challenge.
What I did is worked with
enthusiasts who are keen
to learn new technology, had
that learning culture in them,
and worked with them to
do a lot of experiments
to test out new and emerging technologies.
10, 15 years ago, a lot of
this stuff was very new.
So one of the first things you see
on the top left is we built Alexa skills.
Amazon had just launched
Alexa then to figure out
how consumers would
engage with voice systems.
We built IoT sensors
that help manufacturing teams figure out
how automation can be accelerated,
and a number of other such things
over time did more and more of this,
eventually including the
families of some of our employees
because nothing gets people excited more
than having their kids learn
new technology as well.
So there were a number of
learnings I personally had
that we will share about this now,
and now I'll invite Tom
to share his background on this space.
- Thank you, Arvind.
My name is Tom Soderstrom,
and I was NASA's first CTO
at NASA Jet Proportion Laboratory.
And the slide
that you see here was the attempt
at how can we spend less money on IT
and more on science and engineering.
And we looked at cloud
computing as one of the answers,
and yes, it worked.
And you can see the journey
here from 2008 and beyond,
and the idea was that
if we could use cloud
and AWS saw a business for it,
then they would build it
and we would help launch it.
That's how we came up with so many
of the services that you today use.
So the secret here for you
all is if you are interested
in something that AWS is interested in,
you have an extremely strong voice,
not just for what is
built but how it's built.
So, and of course, we're gonna
talk about some trends here.
I was the futurist at Jet
Proportion Laboratory as the CTO.
And who in here considers
themself their responsibility
to keep understanding
what the technology landscape looks like?
Show of hands. Oh, good, good.
Then we have a gift for you
'cause it's a damn hard job, honestly.
So what we did is it
was fun to hear you talk
about (stammers) or Alexa.
She's not listening, is she? (laughs)
Because one of the first things we saw is
when we came up with
GovCloud, and AWS built it,
it created psychological safety
for people to innovate
in all kinds of ways.
Have you ever heard of
a two-way door decision?
That is the way of using the cloud.
So we created the first NASA Alexa app,
and it's called NASA Mars.
So it still runs.
But this is about technologies,
and what we're gonna talk about is,
so you have this dual
mandate of figuring out
what are the technologies that are coming,
and at the same time,
keep the plane flying.
So we're gonna have this in two pieces.
We looked at the trends that are coming,
we looked at it manually,
and we're gonna share what they are.
And at the end of this,
I'm gonna ask you to
bring your cell phones up
and see what you care about,
which ones you think are interested.
But then we're going to then show you
how you can do this automatically.
So this will be our gift to you all.
So what are the major technology trends?
You are already looking at it.
And the point is not to predict
what's coming in the world.
The point is to predict for your company,
how will it make you more
productive, more profitable?
How will it save money using
these new technologies?
In fact, if you build it, they
will come if you guess right.
Or if you don't wanna build it,
then somebody else will build it,
and that's what we how we worked at NASA.
So when you are looking at
the future and you are wrong,
it's easy to be ridiculed,
and you can see some
of these fun ones here.
I'm very happy that he was
wrong about the airplane,
otherwise we'd be speaking
to a very empty room.
So if you predict right,
you can get a first mover advantage,
you can excite your people to participate,
you can impact the creators
of what's being built
and you can also get a
first mover advantage,
or you can detect very
early that you're way off
and this trend doesn't matter.
So now we'll go a little
deeper into each of these,
but these are the eight that
we saw were interesting,
and two of them are more
questionable than the others.
And I think you can guess
which ones they are,
but we'll find out.
So cloud and generative
AI belong together.
You really cannot be
successful in generative
or agentic AI without using the cloud.
It just needs that much horsepower.
In 2020, we were experimenting.
We were trying to see what we could do
with generative AI and beyond.
In 2025, we're generating
ROI, return on investment,
or are we?
With a show of hands,
how many people here have in
production a generative AI
that is generating an ROI?
Raise your hands very proudly if you do.
Okay, it looks to be about 5%.
All right, what about agentic AI?
Do you have something in production?
One person, two, three, four.
I feel like a salesman here.
(audience laughing)
Is it generating ROI?
Next year when we ask the same question,
a lot of hands will go up.
That's the nature of these technologies,
and $15.7 trillion estimate,
that's a big number.
And new jobs that'll be created.
We think about AI stealing
our jobs, et cetera.
It's actually going to create new jobs,
and your opportunity
is to create those jobs
and staff them with your own
people to see if they pay out.
If they do, you are way ahead of the game.
And if you're right,
then you couldn't afford to
hire those people later anyway.
So it's a good way to just brainstorm
what are the new roles that will come.
Now when we think about it,
Arvind and I thought
about this long and hard,
what is AI in real?
So remember hailing a taxi.
Actually, is there anybody from New York?
You probably do that today.
You trusted that they would stop for you.
Then later on,
you trusted that if you
clicked your smartphone,
they would come and get you.
What we're seeing is this judgment is now
that the self-driving car,
you will trust that the car
will get you there safely.
So it's all about judgment.
This happens to be Zoox.
Has anybody been in a Zoox?
They're here in Las
Vegas. It's fun. (laughs)
I highly recommend you do it.
But it's this trust.
And when we look at AI at scale,
anybody use Rufus to help you shop?
It's awesome, ask for a coffee maker
that is easiest to clean, and
it'll give you an example.
The other thing that we don't see
is regular machine
learning is not going away.
For instance, Rufus on the back end,
filters out 275 million fake reviews
so you don't have to look at them.
It turns out the reviews is
one of the most popular things.
So generative AI, the benefit of this is
that this is working at scale.
So it's AI, it's moving
forward, we're already there.
But what's coming?
It's where AI is becoming
a personal assistant.
It's where the future of education.
Anybody have young
children who ask, "Why,"
over and over and over?
Well, AI doesn't get tired.
AI will engage the student
and it will help them learn
the way they want to do.
Amazon CTO Werner Vogels
said, and I'll quote this,
"When you use tool to
engage curiosity instead
of enforcing compliance,
schools bring to life
and that changes everything."
I think that's really key.
And for the teachers,
they can now use generative
AI and agentic AI
for the drudgery, grading
the reports, et cetera.
So it's really about how we use AI.
So you'll hear a lot about
generative AI and agentic AI
at this conference
because it is the future.
If you were through the
cloud evolution like I was,
this is at least as big, if not bigger,
and it's really exciting.
If you went through the cloud evolution,
take those lessons
learned and you can now go
through the agentic revolution.
So productive at the edge.
Anybody heard the word IoT?
You're tired of it. It didn't
pay out, didn't have any ROI.
Well, that's changing
because we have 20 billion devices today.
By 2030, we would have 40 billion devices,
and they will be connected
and they cannot send data all the time.
So what we're gonna see is we're gonna see
that the return on investment
between business outcome
and being productive
at the edge is gonna be key.
Today, we talk about
large language models.
Tomorrow, we're gonna talk
about nano language models
where the AI will run on
the device, better silicon,
smaller models, and it
will create a digital twin.
I'll talk about that in a second.
But what are some people
who are doing this well?
Kone, anybody know who that is?
Anybody ever run an
elevator or an escalator?
They keep the cities running.
They have 30,000 maintenance technicians.
It's a Finnish company.
They go in 80,000 customer calls per day,
and 30,000 customer calls
per month is filtered out
because of agentic AI.
They have everything at their fingertips.
When they go to fix an elevator,
they know the version,
they know the history,
what usually goes wrong, and
they're much more productive.
So IoT at the edge is really powerful.
We also have AI in the jungle.
I just like saying that.
AI in the jungle is Hexagon,
a Swedish Swiss company,
has a subsidiary called R-evolution,
and it's about measuring biodiversity.
So they have a device
that sits in the jungle
and measures biodiversity over time.
It's sitting at the
edge and it reports back
when it has connectivity,
and that's nice because we do
wanna save the environment.
But if you are a mining company
and you want to do a mine,
you have to prove
that you are actually not
disturbing biodiversity.
So there's business reasons for AI
and IoT at the edge.
So we're gonna see these massive digital
scale twins, digital twins.
And what it means is that
they're collecting the data
at the edge, they're reporting
it back into the cloud,
and now you have a copy in the cloud
of what is in the physical space.
So now you can start
doing what-if analysis.
You can inject faulty data
and you can have a conversation
with all of that data in
the digital twin using what?
Generative AI.
Anybody who've been affected by a wildfire
or knows somebody affected by a wildfire?
Yeah, I live in LA, so very affected.
But it's coming faster and faster,
and natural disasters
are coming more and more.
How do you deal with it?
This is where we see the rise
of augmented reality again,
where you can insert people
into a difficult or dangerous
or far remote place without
them having to be there,
and they can interact with a digital twin
to see how fast the fire is spreading,
what it detected early.
There's a company here called voxelis.ai,
they're on the third floor
of the Venetian here,
and they have a device that
they put on helicopters,
and now the helicopters can just measure
how is there a fire spot coming up
or in the middle of fighting the fire.
And it's a startup of about 20 people.
And what we're seeing is
we're seeing the benefit
of having startups,
working with governments,
working with universities,
especially on things at the edge and AI.
So if you're in that space,
you are in luck, it's growing fast.
Now they will need access,
and if you've heard of
Kuiper, forget that,
it's called Leo, low Earth orbit,
and that is to be able to
provide internet access
to underserved places in the world.
They're also here at re:Invent,
and I highly recommend
a conversation with them
because it's much cheaper and much faster
and lower latency than anything
we've ever seen before.
Countries can now get back
up too if a fiber was cut
and the devices at the edge
can get internet access.
Three, number three here is
robots and cobots at scale.
What on earth is a cobot?
Collaborative robots.
We're seeing people and
robots working together,
and it's $165 billion
market in just a few years.
That's a big number.
All of these have a cumulative,
we picked them because they're
very large dollar amount
and they have a very large
cumulative growth rate,
annual growth rate.
So these robots,
they are amazing.
So they're everywhere,
they're on the moon.
Of course, I care about
that, being from NASA.
But if you think about
something unpleasant
for a second, wars, they're
being fought with drones.
But what we're seeing is we're
seeing much faster adoption
in the civilian space from things
that grew up in the defense space.
We're seeing people who fight
fires use the same technology
that people who fight wars.
Also, we're seeing people actually
form relationship with robots.
If you have a Roomba, raise
your hand if you have a Roomba.
Keep your hand up if you named it.
Half people named their Roomba.
In Sweden where I grew up,
they have automatic lawnmowers.
100% named them, it becomes a pet.
And we find that these robots in hospital,
kids will interact with
them and be much calmer.
Aging people will have a companion
and they need less medicine and less care.
So it really becomes key.
Now for us in Amazon,
if you've been in a fulfillment center,
if you haven't, I highly recommend it.
It's a toy box for robotics.
So if you look at the
person on the top left,
she's stuffing things that you bought,
and the red boxes say don't put it here
because it's close to
something that looks similar.
And so she doesn't have the cognitive load
of having to decide where to pick it.
It saves a lot of time.
On the right is a robot doing
the same thing, augmenting it,
but going high and going
low, so to save her back.
In the lower left-hand corner,
the picker is giving a right
a white angle where to pick,
picks it from there,
picks it, scans it, done.
Fewer errors, much faster.
And then we have the slam process
where in those few seconds
that you see there, this
is actually in real time,
it is taking all the big data
and it's putting it on the label,
who is it and where are they going to.
The box is already sealed,
so there's complete privacy.
Now how big is this? It's huge.
The fulfillment centers
for instance delivered 600
million packages the same day,
and that is going up.
So the speed is about three
hours from start to finish
in the fulfillment center.
The average delivery is 1.9
days from that you bought it,
and the average time to
buy is about three minutes.
So this is speeding up and going faster,
and robotics is helping.
But how do they deliver?
In the last mile,
you have the driver now being able
to use the same technology.
You can see there, it's
gonna shine a red light,
don't pick that one,
and then a green light,
that's the one to deliver.
That saves a minute per
delivery, which is a lot.
Now you add augmented reality glasses
and they can now do the
same thing with hands free.
So everything builds on
everything else here.
What we're seeing is medical impacts
at scale is another one.
In 2020, we never went
to a remote doctor visit.
Well, then came COVID.
In one month, it increased
157% or 157 times.
And now we're looking at it,
yeah, you can actually
have a doctor's visit.
We're wearing wearables.
We're counting ourselves.
Can we sleep better? Et cetera.
And that is going towards
its personal AI guardian.
Genomics is an area that use
a lot of data, a lot of AI,
and you can even in the future
be able to get a prescription
before you even know
that you have the disease
because it looks at the genomic data
and it tells you what you need to do.
So it becomes your guardian.
And it's a big business.
And this genomics is not
just good for people,
it's good for koalas.
I wanna tell this story
about a researcher in Sydney,
Australia who had a lot of genomics data,
but she didn't have the
people and the skills
to analyze it enough.
So she put it in Amazon's
Open Data Exchange,
and a researcher in Sweden
was able to solve it
in just a few days.
And do you know how you save the koala?
You vaccinate them from chlamydia.
Who would have known?
Well, I'm happy to say
that two months ago,
that was actually approved,
that vaccine in Australia.
So there is big hopes for the koala.
The point of that is if you share the data
and you share how you can work faster,
you can do miracles.
And digital twins, it's
not just for things,
it's for humans.
So if I have a disease,
they can have a digital twin of me
'cause everything is being measured,
and they can see where they should operate
before they do it.
And now they can bring in robotics
and have somebody from outside
actually do the surgery.
So the medical impacts are fantastic,
and we're gonna need them.
We lived till
about 47 years old in 1900,
78 in 2000,
and in 2100, it'll be,
I don't have a clue,
but we're gonna live longer
and we will have implants,
and AI is going to be
what keeps us healthy.
So it's just not a new thing.
It's very personal and very important.
The fifth here is data.
There's no surprise to any of
you that data is going faster.
Anybody know what the
biggest number we measure is?
Yottabyte, and yottabyte
was impossibly big.
Well, we're gonna get there in 2030.
So now you need to learn
a new word, quettabytes.
So a quettabyte is 10
with 30 zeros behind it.
So if you learn, what did you call that?
- Kampung.
- Kampung, and now quettabyte.
So you learn so much here. (laughs)
But how you gonna analyze all this data?
We're seeing agentic AI
as being an ability here
to analyze the data that's coming
and to deal with it differently.
And the data is not just structured,
it's unstructured, 90% of it.
And how do you get your arms
around all of this data in your company?
The answer, as uncomfortable
as it is, is you won't.
You won't get your arm around
all the data, but it's okay.
Just think, work backwards on the problem,
and think about the problem
you're trying to solve,
and then use generative AI
to tie into partner's data.
What we're thinking here
is flipping the script.
That's the easiest thing we have seen
successful companies do.
Instead of you having to fill
out a form to use my data,
I have to fill out a
form to protect the data,
and it changes everything
'cause now you can experiment using AI
and internet of things
creates a lot of data
and now you can start analyzing it.
You can also use synthetic data.
Is anybody using synthetic data yet?
Okay, very few.
So this is the hand
scanner called Amazon One.
When I'm out on a run, I
go into an Amazon Fresh,
pick up a bottle of water,
just hold my hand over and run out.
That is because they trained
it with synthetic data,
and it's 99.9999% is very accurate.
It's more accurate than
an iris or a fingerprint,
but it was the synthetic
data that made it happen.
So that's the opportunity here with data.
Six out of eight is crypto,
and crypto revolution,
we may or may not be right,
but if you have invested
in bitcoin 10 years ago,
it would be the single biggest investment
you could have made.
But it's up and down, so it's worrisome.
But now we have regulations
coming and there is growth,
and blockchain keeps going.
So the token economy means
that you will have tokens on,
digital tokens for physical things.
So, and that changes everything.
Have you ever thought about
how an agent will pay another
agent, software agents?
They'll probably use stablecoin,
and they'll probably use micropayments,
a fraction of a fraction
of a fraction of a penny.
So all of a sudden, it
creates a new economy,
and decentralized finance
may be one of them.
Then quantum computing.
So quantum is, we worried
about building the hardware,
and in the left corner
is Amazon's quantum lab
at Caltech, kept in Los Angeles.
Now we've actually made
error-correcting qubits.
So a qubit is not a qubit.
If it's error correcting,
it's 90% faster and better
than a non-error correcting.
And it's a large market.
Where will it go? You can
see it's a big impact.
It's gonna have a lot of jobs.
Where will it go as far
as business applications?
That's gonna be the question and when.
So we think this is one of the key trends
because of the growth
rate and amount of money.
But what applications will we see
and which quantum computer?
So these are four completely
different quantum computers.
We don't know which one will win the ring
that rules them all, but
Amazon provides choice.
So you can Braket to try
and to see which one
makes the biggest impact.
The important part here
is to get your programmers
to try to use quantum computing
to see what you can do.
Then we have Airbus and BMW looking
at being able to do logistics,
being able to soundproof it.
Lot of near-term opportunities.
The biggest one of all,
quantum-safe encryption.
That's where you worry
about the future quantum
computing decrypting your data,
and so that's being worked on.
That's the single biggest
opportunity right now,
and you don't have to wait.
Use AWS as quantum-safe
encryption algorithms.
Others do too. The key here is to use it.
The last one is, do we have
enough energy for this?
We use fossil fuels,
then we use renewables.
And Amazon is the biggest
producer of renewables
and also purchaser of renewables.
And now we're looking at nuclear power.
It's doesn't produce fossil fuel,
but we're gonna need all of this energy.
And it isn't just about energy
to power things like windmills,
it's about your energy
to be able to handle this
and having this dual mandate.
So if you pull out your smartphones,
which of these emerging technologies
will matter the most to you?
If you...
Sorry, there's the QR code.
If you do that, you'll be able to see,
which ones of these do you care about?
Click on all of them,
click on none of them,
and we're gonna see the
results in just a few minutes.
So it looks like agentic AI
and data and energy.
That's a surprise. I didn't expect that.
Crypto, not so much.
Quantum, somewhat.
And otherwise, it's an
even split, I think.
Surprising, not more
people on edge computing,
but this is why what
matters to your company,
and having to do this on
your own is hard work.
So isn't there a better way? Arvind.
- Absolutely.
So in the last 20 minutes,
we've done a kind of whirlwind tour
of eight technology trends
that we felt were important,
but they may or may not
be important for you.
And this thing is moving so fast
that you've got to build
your own capability
to stay in touch with technology trends.
What you need is to upgrade
your cockpit with a radar system
that can do this reconnaissance for you.
What you need is a radar
that can sweep the landscape
on a periodic basis
and identify what
technologies are starting
to appear on the landscape.
And more importantly,
you need a systemic way
that can then identify those technologies,
understand how far are
they from impact with you,
how fast are they moving,
what's the business impact potential,
and how mature are they to make
an impact for your business.
So that's something you
need to continuously do
and be able to share that
with your business leadership
to stay ahead in this
dual mandate situation.
And very importantly, based on this data,
you also need to then be able to tell
if this is a technology
that I should be deploying
in my business right now
because it's making an impact
in my industry, in my
peers and competitors.
Or is this something which is close
to making a business impact,
and therefore we should be starting pilots
or maybe experiments?
Or if it's something which is less mature
but moving fast and
potentially big impact,
this may be something
that requires monitoring.
This is a lot of work,
and Tom and I in our past
have done this manually using
that compound to help us in this journey.
But things are much easier now.
This is 2025, this is the year
where agents can help
you solve this problem.
And we are not just suggesting
that agents can solve
this problem for you,
we actually have a solution for you.
So we, quick story, back story here,
is when we were doing the
research for this talk,
Tom and I, as often
gets happens in Amazon,
we wrote a paper on this topic saying
what CIOs need today is a systemic,
automated way to scan
for technology landscape
and do these assessments and
understand what's important.
And as again, as happens in Amazon,
this paper gets distributed,
and people add to that, provide inputs,
and some of them say, "Hey,
I'll build this for you."
So I want to introduce Jiyun Park,
who's part of our Korea
solution architects team,
and she raised up her
hands and volunteered
and said, "I'll build this for you."
So what we are gonna show you today
and give you today in
fact is an agentic system
that can automate this
entire reconnaissance work.
Jiyun.
(audience clapping)
- Thanks, Arvind.
Hi, everyone, I'm Jiyun.
Today, I'm gonna walk you through
what is the TechRecon
powered by agentic AI.
So before I show you the result,
I'm gonna highly briefly
explain the architecture
of the TechRecon behind the agentic AI.
So the TechRecon is a multi-agent system
that researches public
sources like newspapers,
consulting companies and IT vendors,
and generates a series of
documents to IT leaders
so they can understand the fast-changing,
emerging technologies and
deep dives where they need.
So we have supervisor agent here,
which orchestrates the entire workflow
across the sub agents.
And we define the TechRecon by a prompt.
So it's gonna support the
CIO of the XYZ company
and researching the emerging technologies.
We iterated with this with
many different prompts
and finalize this with the best one.
Inside the system, each
agent has a specialized role
which going on on their respective tasks.
So the planner agents create
tasks for the other agents,
researcher agents gathers the information
and like they actually
research on behalf of human,
coder agents read,
saves, and creates files,
and reporter agents synthesizes everything
and make it as a final output.
And these agents are
work in a sequential way.
So based on the user request,
there's gonna major two outputs,
which is the part one, emerging
tech landscape analysis,
which is gonna cover the broad landscapes
of the technologies,
and part two, position papers
on the specific technology,
which is dive deep on
one specific technology
and creates the report of your
company's position papers.
This is the strength of agentic AI system.
With multiple agents, which
has their specialized role,
they're working together
using their tools they need
and making the final outputs autonomously.
- And as we are working together on this,
what we realize is not only
can it do research for you,
which is gather all of these insights
and convert that into kind
of summarized documents,
but could even do the analysis
we talked about earlier.
So if you build a slide,
what the agents were able to
do using coding capabilities,
et cetera, just click this, yeah,
is we created three measures,
three scores for every
technology that it found.
We calculated an impact score,
and this was based on the work
that actually was done at NASA
on technology-readiness scoring.
And the way this happens is
very specific to your company.
So Jiyun mentioned earlier
that it's designed for your company.
So let's say you are the CIO
of a pharmaceutical company,
it'll do the analysis and impact analysis
for your industry, right?
And similarly, maturity scoring,
which is how ready is this
technology for use today?
And finally, momentum, which
is how fast is this moving?
Is this accelerating or slowing down?
So for every technology,
we were able to create these three scores
and then build, next slide.
And also, what we were able to do,
once you have those scores
and build, one more.
What we were able to do
is based on those scores,
you could actually reach
some sort of judgment
on if this is a technology
which is high impact
and highly mature, and as being right now,
there are examples of use cases
of this making an impact in your industry,
then that's something you
should deploy right now.
But if it's earlier in maturity,
then that may be something you
want to pilot or experiment.
Whereas if there's something else,
which is very early stages, very mature,
but moving fast and
potentially big impact,
that's something you wanna monitor.
Now these were some parameters we chose
as we were experimenting with this,
but you can pick your own parameters
and create how you want to assess
and decide what to do with
each of these technologies.
And now Jiyun will show an actual demo
of how the system works.
- Okay, now I show you the demo,
but before I show you the, play the demo,
I'm gonna briefly explain the
front end of the TechRecon.
So as you can see in the middle,
you can see the real-time logs
as they're being streamed.
So they're gonna be the
outputs of each agents
and display on the middle of the screen.
On the right-hand side,
you can see the control panel
and you can see the status of each agent.
And the below down there,
there's the button so that
you can execute the run,
create the reports, which is the part one,
landscape analysis report,
and part two, technology position papers.
And if all those tests are completed,
you can download all the files
in the bottom-right corner.
Oh.
- [Arvind] That's all right,
I think we can just move forward.
Yeah.
- Okay, so after the demo is completed,
you can see the result,
which is the emerging technologies
reconnaissance report,
which is the part one.
This is the real result you can utilize
in your real world.
So this is the example part one report
for CIO of the Pfizer company.
So if there's anyone here from the Pfizer
or pharmaceutical industry
company and Congress,
you can get this report today.
But otherwise, you can run
this code in your local system
and then just replace the
variables with your industry
and your company name.
So this part one is
gonna cover the overview
of the technology landscape,
strategy recommendations
based on the score assessment,
which is Arvind explained before,
and the industry-specific context as well.
Because the TechRecon follows
the strict fixed template,
so you can run it monthly, quarterly,
or whenever you want
to catch up the new
emerging technology trends.
After creating the
landscape analysis report,
you can create the technology paper,
which dives deeper into
such one technology.
Here, as you can see, the generative AI.
Like as you can see, it
includes the key findings,
strategy recommendations,
technology deep dives,
and also the real-world
use cases you can utilize.
And the TechRecon is not only just covered
this technical thing, it
covers the business as well.
So you can see why this matter for Pfizer
in this report as well.
So the TechRecon is not a new service,
it's a blueprint so that
your teams can deploy
within a few weeks.
On the average,
maybe it's gonna cost them
less than $2,000 per year,
but it depends on how
much you're gonna run.
So it can take less, it can take more.
Many companies don't know where to start.
They actually want to
build the agentic AI,
but they don't know where to start.
This is why the TechRecon is so powerful,
and you can start it today.
We're gonna give you the code architecture
and the implementation guide today.
So you can run this
and build your own strategy
advisor with the TechRecon.
So this is the technical thing.
Then what about the human side?
Tom is gonna introduce it.
- So I'm not sure it was clear.
The system actually write, it
scans the technology for you,
and it writes those reports.
That's what you're gonna be asked for.
That's what the dual mandate is.
So you get a lot of help
from what Jiyun built.
But it's not about technology
alone, it's about people.
So I want you, on three,
to yell out what COE means.
One, two, three.
- [Audience] Center of excellence.
- But it shouldn't.
So I created a center of
excellence for cloud at NASA,
and we've seen many companies do that.
What do you do?
You create a center of people
who think they're excellent,
and everybody else hates them,
(audience laughing)
and then they create their
own center of excellence.
So you now don't have just
shadow IT, you have shadow COEs.
So isn't there a better way? There is.
With all of these new
technologies that are coming,
what you really want is you want
to work backwards on the business problem
and you want the center of engagement.
You want people to try
it, experiment with it,
and be able to very scrappy test it.
And if it pays out business
dividends, you double down.
So you think big, start
small with these experiments,
then scale fast.
But they're business experiments,
not technology experiments.
And trust me, the companies
we talk to, this works,
and the people who do it get promoted.
So this is the way to
actually test, try this out.
Now the other thing that
it does is it engages teams
and people beyond your organization.
I mean, you're all sitting here,
and hopefully you're talking to each other
because that's the future collaborators
that you're gonna have.
So the TechRecon center
of excellence can now reach
out to business units,
as many as you can, and
then to external partners,
and the entire ecosystem intelligence.
And you will start feeding
each other information
that you're looking for,
and perhaps even create new
partnerships with these agents.
And it all starts with the tech COE,
or I'm sorry, the
technology reconnaissance
that Jiyun built.
But how do you fund it?
How do you prove that this is worthwhile?
Arvind, how did you fund it?
- Yeah, so I would say that the human side
of this is probably the most
important investment needed,
but you do need some dollars as well.
And in my experience as
we got this thing going,
one of the most important things was for
to create the fuel for
innovation that we all,
you know, hope we'll go to
our CFO and CEO and say,
"Hey, we need to stay in touch
with emerging technologies,
and please fund it."
It's very hard to get funding for that.
The way I've always done that is
to start the innovation process,
the new technology
application process in areas
that generate some savings first,
and then I have the agreement
with the CEO and the CFO
that instead of taking that
saving to the bottom line,
we'll reinvest this into more innovation.
And that's the reason I
call it fuel for innovation.
And once you have the
technical capability,
the human side of it, and
this little bit of funding,
then the way you want
to think about this is
to get your flywheel
of emerging technology
and innovation going.
The way Amazon likes to look
at flywheels is you think
of this as a flywheel,
you need to give it a start
by getting some business
leadership engagement,
attracting talent into it,
you get the right talent,
the right ideas for innovation come up,
and you make them successful,
you invest in making the
early ones successful,
and that gets your flywheel going.
And as you gather momentum,
more and more ideas are generated
and more impact of business happens.
And as someone who's trying
to get this TechRecon capability going,
unless you want to do
this all by yourself,
you've got to think about
how the flywheel is running
and how you can accelerate it further.
So that was one of the
areas that we focused on.
And a common learning
that both Tom and I had was oftentimes,
a question that gets asked is ROI,
and what I have done
sometimes successfully,
sometimes not very successfully,
is kind of shift that conversation to ROA,
which is a return on attention.
What truly matters when you're looking
at emerging technologies
and early stages is,
are there ideas that actually
business cares about?
Are they paying attention to this?
Are they putting effort into
exploring this and figuring out
how this can create value for them?
And the way we measure that is through
how much engagement are we getting?
Are people showing up?
Are they volunteering to
be part of this ecosystem?
Is the velocity of the
ideas that are moving
and the ideas that are
moving from early stage
to actual experimentation growing?
And finally most importantly,
is this leading to strategic conversations
in the executive room saying,
"Look, here are the 10
technologies which are coming up.
These have potential, we
want to do experiments
with these three, watch
these five, et cetera."
That is the sign that this COE is working
for us or not.
Now there are many challenges
to making it work, of course.
This is not straightforward.
The common issue
in the earlier stages is
you launch this thing,
and nobody shows up.
No one has time, everyone's very busy.
This is a classic issue.
And again, investing in
the early few projects
in a way that saves dollars as well
as capacity is very useful.
I found that always very helpful.
But more importantly, it's
about creating that culture.
Leadership has to convey the message
that learning is important,
not just for this job
and this company today,
but for your careers in the future.
The second thing that often
comes in the way is everyone,
once you get people excited,
everyone wants to work on
the same hot technology.
And if you truly want
to look at a portfolio
of emerging technologies,
you want more people
to be interested in different things.
And there are many ways to do that
by making sure that the
portfolio is very clear
and you move people from
one idea to the other
and not gonna let everyone
get focused on the same thing.
And finally, very importantly,
your business has to feel like
it's their problem to solve.
If that's not happening,
so you have to work backwards
from where the business
opportunities are, right?
So with that, hopefully we've
given you a lot of ideas
on how to do this.
We have seen, and you know,
that it's possible in a 90-day period
to get this whole engine
and this flywheel going.
In the first month or so
using now what's possible
with TechRecon, the agentic tool,
you can actually set
the foundation in place
and have the conversation with your CEO
and CFO that this is something
as an organization you
wanna put more attention on.
In the second month,
you can start looking at some
of these position papers,
get people to own it,
build more detail into it.
And by month three,
you should be going into
your executive boardrooms
and having a conversation
about what are the technologies
you want to keep an eye on
and potentially do experiments with.
Now I make it sound very simple.
This is not like a silver bullet,
of course.
There are challenges, but
this is becoming so important
for us in our roles as CIOs
that this is not something
that can be ignored.
We have to figure out a way
to manage our operational
delivery responsibilities
while also building the muscle
to do technology reconnaissance.
And so hopefully with that,
what you should be able
to do is this future.
(radar beeping)
(airplane dings)
- [CEO] What's our position
on the new AI regulations?
- [Pilot] Already briefed
the board last week.
Position paper sent to your tablet.
(airplane dings)
- [Board Member] How
will quantum computing
affect our encryption?
- [Pilot] We've been monitoring
quantum developments.
Recommend moving to
quantum-resistant encryption
in quarter two.
Full analysis, ready for review.
(airplane engine whirring)
- All right, so with that,
we want you to go out and
conquer the dual mandate.
You have a lot of resources here.
You will have access to
actually the source code
for TechRecon is posted.
You can access that.
We'll be hanging around for a few minutes.
We'll actually redo the demo as well
since that didn't work earlier.
But very importantly,
this week is an amazing set
of folks who are around here.
There are people,
everyone who's in this
gathering hopefully are folks
who want to build this capability.
So talk to each other, connect with them.
Go to the expo floor, go to the replay.
There's a lot of new technology on demo.
Get to see that and learn how that works.
So with that, we'd love to-
- Just one more point.
When I asked you how many had
agentic-something running,
like two people raised their hands.
Here's your opportunity to have
an agentic-something running
- Yes. (laughs)
- that is very low risk,
it's very low cost,
but it gets you started.
While she's setting up the
demo, it's two minutes,
what you can actually
see, what you would get,
it's worth it because
people will get interested.
As we started doing this,
we realized it was not
at all what we thought.
Like in the beginning,
you may think an agent is an intern
where you can just tell an
intern, "Go do something."
You can't do that with an agent.
So that prompt that she
showed is very, very telling.
It came from a lot of iteration.
So it gives you a chance to get hands on.
So two minutes, and you'll see this now.
- We'll just do the demo again. Thank you.
- Yeah, sorry.
So as soon as you click the Run button,
the supervisor agent
takes all the controls
of the entire workflow,
and the planner agents begins the planning
of the researcher, coder,
and reporter agent is gonna run.
So actually, you can
see the real-time logs
as they're being streamed from each agent,
which is the specifically
the planner agent right now.
And basically, the planner
identifies what needs to be done.
So once the planner finishes
generating the task list
that the researcher, coder,
and reporter agents begin
executing their respective tasks
and start filling in their information.
So when all the tasks are completed,
you can see on the right-hand
side, the control plane,
all the agents' status is
gonna change to Completed,
and the generated files
become available for,
down the bottom-right corner,
you can download it, all the files.
So after you create the part one,
you can proceed to part two.
So it's gonna generate this specific
technology position
papers, which is gonna,
based on the part one assessment scores,
the higher ranked assessment scores.
- So if you go to the last slide,
just so they can see where to download it,
but it's an open source, it's a blueprint.
It gives you a chance to
have this dual mandate.
It's hard, but once you've set it up,
let's say you have a
board meeting tomorrow
and they ask you to come in
and talk to the board of directors,
which will happen with agentic AI,
you can just run this and
have the latest report.
It creates it for you.
That's kind of the key.
It saves you time.
So...
- So thank you.
We'll hang around here.
If anyone wants to actually
implement this, Jiyun is here.
And through that GitHub
link, you can of course,
get access to the code,
the instructions there,
and you can also reach
out to us for any support
or help needed to make it work.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)